So, Stream außerhalb mal der Reihe, so komplett random, wobei, das erweckt jetzt ja fast den Anschein, als hätte ich regelmäßige Streamzeiten oder sowas in der Richtung, was natürlich nicht der Fall ist.
So, funktioniert das hier? Guck mal, Unity Media scheint zu tun, äh, sorry, Vodafone, Vodafone, scheint ja alles zu gehen, um die Leute mal ein bisschen zu triggern.
Ich finde es immer geil, wie viele Leute da drauf anspringen.
Warum haben wir da ein Schachvideo? Warum habe ich ein excellent, exquisite, big brain Schachvideo auf dem Desktop?
Richtige Hacker-Man einfach, da geht sonst nix.
Schriebenstellen ist am Donnerstag, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich sag ja, komplett außerhalb der Reihe, ne?
Komplett außerhalb der Reihe.
Komm, wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen Aquarium an.
Dein Corona-Video war nice. Oh, das ist schön, wenn dir das gefallen hat.
Habt ihr alle schon mal ein neues YouTube-Video gesehen?
Ich habe hier tatsächlich ein neues Video hochgeladen und ich lade noch zwei andere hoch.
Ich lade einmal noch ein Video hoch über Boomer im Homeoffice, Alter.
Die letzten Tage, ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen, ähm.
Du hast, oh, Moment, ich sehe es gerade, ich muss mein Pepega-Board wieder anschmeißen.
Sonst haben wir die Fragen, sonst übersehe ich die Fragen wieder.
Wo ist es? Da ist es, hier, Pepega-Board.
Zack, da ist das Aquarium.
So, ach, du warst das nicht.
Gerne.
Das muss ich richtig zuordnen.
Ah, ja, das ist exzellent, exzellent.
Der YouTube-Streak, da weiß ich nicht, ob der YouTube-Streak anfängt.
Ich muss gerade mal chatten, ich sehe euch gerade nicht.
Ich refreshe nämlich gerade mal den Chat.
So, jetzt sehe ich euch wieder.
Kommt gar nicht auf...
Oh, mein Sound ist weg.
Äh, jetzt ist mein Sound wieder da.
What the fuck?
Hä?
Ich weiß nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat, aber gut.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Jetzt müssen wir mal kurz bei Windows überprüfen, ob das Sound noch richtig funktioniert.
Weil manchmal spackt der ja rum aus nicht näher erkennbaren Gründen.
Da müssen wir ziemlich mal gucken.
Das Sound funktioniert.
Achtung.
Ditteldimm, ditteldimm.
Excellent.
Funktioniert.
Yes.
Und der hier, der hier sollte knistern.
Der sollte nicht funktionieren.
Und wenn das so ist, dann ist alles richtig eingestellt.
Ja, ja.
Richtig, der knistert.
Also lassen wir den aus.
Sehr gut, der Sound ist richtig.
Funktioniert alles.
Äh, mein...
Lautstärke ist auch okay.
Sehr schön.
Sonst machen wir das komisch mal gleich da.
Gleich da Icon...
Icon weg.
Weil ich bin...
Ich bin ja schon da.
Habt ihr...
Habt ihr mal ein neues Video geguckt?
Wollen wir mal ein neues Video...
Na komm, wir können später nochmal mal ein neues Video zusammen gucken.
Ähm, ja.
Ey, ihr glaubt nicht, ne?
Was hier beim Thema Homeoffice, Leute.
Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen.
Ich hab das Gefühl, die Hälfte der Leute hat noch nie in ihrem Leben voice chatten.
Und man darf jetzt nicht vergessen, das sind Leute, die arbeiten in der IT und die verdienen ihr Geld mit IT.
Das darf man nicht vergessen, ja.
Die haben sich...
Die stellen sich alle an.
Und in jeder Besprechung, weil wie gesagt, wir haben ja Microsoft Teams mittlerweile.
Und in jeder Besprechung...
Und in jeder Besprechung hast du irgendeinen Typ, der es nicht schafft, Push-to-Talk zu machen.
Oder Teams kann ja kein Push-to-Talk.
Teams kann ja nur manuell muten, manuell unmuten.
Was im Endeffekt sowas wie Push-to-Talk ist, ne?
Ähm, in jeder Besprechung hast du da fünf Leute, wenn es genug sind, die im Hintergrund Handy-Klingeln haben.
Die dann irgendwelche Tastatur-geile Hackermans machen auf der Tastatur im Hintergrund.
Die kriegen das alle nicht gebacken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was da dran so schwer ist.
A-Yo-Key.
Dankeschön für die drei Monate Prime-Sub.
Oh, Leute, soll ich euch mal ein Video zeigen?
Ist das ihr Bar?
Oder?
Das ist für die Weebs im Chat.
Das ist was.
Das gefällt euch.
Das kann ich euch gleich sagen.
Das findet ihr super.
Der Martin abonniert.
Acht Monate.
Huge Sub.
Dankeschön.
Big Fadrich.
Big Prames.
Big, big, big Prime.
Big Prames-Sub.
Oh, richtig echter.
Gar kein Prime.
Richtig echter.
Und zwar, das wurde mir letztens...
Das wurde...
Wo hab ich denn das Video?
Ähm, ich hab mir das...
Ich hab mir das extra...
Extra kopiert, weil ich mir gedacht hab...
Chat.
Das...
Das muss ich...
Das muss ich dem Chat zeigen.
Der Chat freut sich.
Oh, das Scam-Train, Leute.
Das ist so geil.
Warum ist mein Sound wieder weg?
Mein Sound ist wieder weg.
Äh, Tribun und ich guck da schon gar nicht mehr rein.
Ich guck da schon gar nicht mehr rein.
Kurz mal...
Kurz...
Inkognito-Tab.
Nicht, dass wir noch mehr Videos dieser Art empfohlen bekommen.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt auch nicht an.
Ich dachte mir nur, dass das...
Dass das hier...
Den...
Den Anime-Fans garantiert gefällt im Chat.
Und zwar...
Videotitel ist...
Moment, muss ich mal nachgucken, wie...
Videotitel ist, dass ich...
Dass ihr gleich wisst, worauf ihr euch...
Wo...
Fuck, Alter.
Warum geht immer mein Sound aus heute?
Geht er bei euch auch aus?
Oder hört ihr mich weiter und nur ich höre mich selbst nicht?
WTF?
Mein Sound geht die ganze Zeit an und aus.
Was ist denn das?
Man hört mich, okay.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal die Soundkarte reinziehen und wieder reinstecken.
Also, der Videotitel ist...
Ich sag einfach nichts, ey.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Wie guckt man sich an?
Ich sag's nur.
Was es nicht alles gibt, Alter.
WTF?
Was ist das?
Corona-Chan-Infektio.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ey, das hat übelst...
Oh, oh.
Sexually...
Ach du Scheiße.
Sexually-Infektio.
Mokka-Tossal.
Manchmal...
Manchmal verstehe ich das...
Die Welt nicht mehr, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, was ist denn da schon wieder los?
Das wäre was für ein Sibaro.
Eindeutig.
Eindeutig, ja.
Matt S. U. Fini 98.
Vier Monate.
Dankeschön.
Nee, nix RIP.
Homeoffice läuft super.
Damit haben wir noch am Start hier.
Der Felix ist am Start.
Sieben Monate.
Boah, Gott.
Ich mach mal kurz meine Soundkarte raus und wieder rein.
Irgendwie...
Irgendwie spackt das gerade über USB rum.
So.
Jetzt sollte eigentlich klar alles funktionieren, hoffe ich mal.
Ah.
Blink, blink, blink.
Blink.
Äh.
WTF?
Die Soundkarte ist immer richtig angegangen.
Das ist eine 600 Euro Soundkarte.
Die soll das mal nicht abkacken.
Was soll das?
WTF?
Was ist jetzt?
Jetzt, wo Unity Media funktioniert, spackt die Soundkarte rum.
Ich glaub's.
Jetzt kommst du hier vor, als wir sabotiert laufen.
Ähm.
Die Kirby-Musik ist mir doch ein bisschen zu entspannend, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber dann nicht nur...
Irgendwas anderes.
Bisschen Wupp-Wupp, im Zweifelsfall.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache, es ist ein bisschen Hintergrundgeräusch am Start.
So.
Ähm.
Dann hab ich noch mal ne Frage an euch, Chat.
So.
Und zwar...
Ich hab schon auf Twitter gefragt, aber so hundertprozentig schlau bin ich da draus nicht geworden.
Aber ich weiß ja, dass hier der Chat, der ist ja hier, ne, absolut massive IQ.
Ich hab hier aktuell in meinem Rechner folgenden Arbeitsspeicher.
Ja.
Hast du natürlich schon die Refuse to Half-Life Alyx angeguckt.
Soll der beste VR-Shooter ever sein.
Mein Problem ist, ich würd's mir gerne holen.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock drauf, mir nur nen VR-Headset zu holen, einfach für ein Game und danach vergammelt's.
Wobei, ich hab sogar nen Geizhals-Link.
Also, guck mal, Leute.
Ich hab jetzt aktuell...
Wie viele...
Doch, VR-Shooter gibt's sogar ein paar.
Nicht, dass mir jetzt ein Name einfallen würde, aber ich weiß, dass es ein paar gibt.
So.
Ähm...
Also, mir geht's nicht, dass der RGB hat.
Das da ist der RAM.
Der hat irgendwie 3200 MHz Takt.
Wobei, das ist DDR, das ist ja nur Fake-Takt im Endeffekt.
Und das sind hier die Zugriffszeiten.
Jetzt mal die Frage an den huge Big-Brain-Chat.
Ich hab ja schon auf Twitter gefragt und Twitter war so...
War der Meinung, das funktioniert wohl ganz gut.
Lohnt sich das für ein Ryzen-System?
Ich mein, der RAM ist nicht schlecht, ja.
Der RAM ist, zack.
Ist ziemlich schnell.
Ich mein, die Alternative wär 3600.
Ähm...
Von den Zugriffszeiten her ist das ziemlich geschwind.
Also, so im Bereich, wo man sich den Kram noch gut leisten kann und dass es nicht extrem teuer wird.
Ähm...
Weil ich überleg mir doch grad, ob ich mir nicht doch noch jetzt ein Ryzen-System hole.
Ich hab ja letztes Jahr schon überlegt.
Aber irgendwie...
Ich hätte gerne einfach 16 Kerne.
Oder 12 oder 16 Kerne.
Ja, nee, ich hab mir aber kein Ryzen gekauft, weil ich damals gesagt hab, mir reicht das Ganze.
So.
Und ich hab nämlich mittlerweile 32G.
Also ich hab hier drinnen...
Ich hab hier 16.
Und ich hab aber noch ne Packung hier liegen mit dem gleichen RAM.
Nochmal 16.
Äh, da.
Memory.
Warum ist eigentlich so viel Memory belegt?
Es ist nichts auf.
Okay, Windows.
Alles klar.
Es läuft ne VM, in der nix läuft.
Und...
Browser.
Ist das echt ding...
Einfach mal, einfach mal 12G belegt.
Viele Chromium-Tabs...
Oh ja...
Sechs Stück.
Wahnsinn.
Zeit mal im Task-Mantel.
Ja, lass mal gucken.
Ähm...
Ah.
Äh...
Nichts belegt so viel RAM.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach RAM, der mal angefordert wurde und noch nicht explizit wieder
freigegeben ist, um zu testen.
Ich hab jetzt hier mal...
Hm.
Ich hab hier noch ne Packung.
Äh...
wieder freigegeben ist, sondern sobald man ihn
braucht, wieder benutzt werden kann.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so wild.
So.
Memory.
Nicht viel, oder?
Ja. Ist doch der Witz.
Ich meine, es ist ein bisschen fragwürdig, warum Chrome
überhaupt
16x16 Threads laufen hat
und einen Gigabyte RAM braucht für 6 Tabs.
Aber da habe ich mich ja schon dran gewöhnt mittlerweile.
Du hattest heute Spotify bei
23G. Ja, es leben
Elektron-Anwendungen, beziehungsweise reine
Browser-Anwendungen. Beste.
Vielleicht kann ich den RAM auch ein bisschen übertanken. Das ist eigentlich
eine gute Idee. User32
DLL.
Wollte ich mal gucken.
Aber wenn schon, hole ich mir ein Dingschen.
Das ist so für mich die beste
Kombi. Das Ding hat ordentlich...
Und eine Sache habe ich noch nicht so ganz
kapiert. Spotify ist Elektron
wahrscheinlich. Im Zweifelsfall ist Spotify Elektron.
Das ganze Browser...
Das sind alles
Browser-Anwendungen.
Eine Sache habe ich noch
nicht ganz gecheckt, was
Ryzen angeht. Und übertakten und sowas.
Man kann ja wohl... Wobei, ich habe
es schon gecheckt, aber ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob das
100%ig stimmt.
So.
Nämlich, man kann
Ryzen... Also das Ding
übertaktet sich von Haus aus wie alle anderen
halbwegs modernen CPUs. Also sprich,
wenn man nur einen Kern braucht, geht das bis auf
4,7 GHz hoch. Wobei,
der Bauer hat ja mal ein Video gemacht,
dass die 4,7 seltenst
erreicht werden und meistens irgendwie so ein 4,5
oder sowas.
Was man jetzt machen kann ist,
man kann die Dinger ja übertakten.
So quasi diese All-Core
All-Core-Enhancement.
Also sprich, dass man alle
Kerne auf den Takt setzt.
Damit verliert man halt dieses
dynamische sich selbst übertakten.
Oder das ist das
besser gesagt, das ist die Frage. Verliert man damit
das dynamische selbst übertakten?
Spotify ist
Q2WebView. Ja, das ist ja
auch nicht viel besser als Elektronik.
Das ist im Prinzip auch Chrome mittlerweile.
Die Q2WebEngine
ist, das ist auch ein Chrome.
So, und die Frage ist jetzt nur, entweder
habe ich sie richtig kapiert oder es lohnt sich
wirklich nicht. Weil was man machen kann ist,
das Ding übertaktet sich ja selbst
je nach Auslastung
bis auf 4,7, besser gesagt 4,5
weil die 4,7 reines
Marketinggelaber sind von AMD.
Wenn man jetzt All-Core übertaktet,
Übertaktung macht, dann kann man
die eben nicht auf
4,5, 4,7 setzen, sondern
sagen wir mal so, vielleicht
mit viel Glück auf 4,4
wahrscheinlich eher 4,3.
So, und das heißt auch im Endeffekt, wenn ich
das jetzt richtig verstanden habe,
All-Core übertakten beim Ryzen
bringt nur
was, wenn ich
permanent Multicore
brutalsten Multicore-Workload
habe, den ich mit 16 Kernen
garantiert nicht habe.
Oder? Weil ansonsten
fahre ich wahrscheinlich besser, wenn
er sich dynamisch selbst hochtaktet
auf eventuell bis zu 4,7.
Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Das ist ja schon mal gut.
Huge.
Ja, ich habe ja durch den Chat mittlerweile auch
Massive IQ. So viele Leute
wie schon gesubbt haben.
Das ist der Platz, der Kopf.
So ist das also. Gut, dann habe ich das
richtig verstanden, dann ist es total bescheuert.
So, und dann brauche ich
noch eine andere Sache.
Die ganzen ultra-teuren Boards
lohnen doch überhaupt nicht, oder?
Was ich mir jetzt rausgesucht habe, ist ein
boah, was? Z
470?
Heißen die Z 470?
Nee, oh Gott, wie heißen die Dinger?
Äh, meine Güte, ich kann mir den Kram nicht mehr...
Was? X 470?
Ah ja.
Das da?
Ich glaube, nee. Ach du Kacke.
Kann man das nicht merken. Zumindest
das, das, das habe ich mir
als Mainboard rausgesucht.
Äh, aber nicht das
X500. Hier, das da.
X, X, das, das da. Das da.
Das. So.
Und, ähm, das hat mir
eigentlich preis-leistungsmäßig ganz gut
gefallen. Was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied zwischen?
Ultimate, nicht Ultimate.
Ah, das kostet 50 Euro mehr.
Brauchen wir nicht. So.
Äh, PC
Express 4.5, ganz ehrlich, geht mir
voll am Arsch vorbei.
Ähm, so. Das fand ich, das fand ich
eigentlich ganz gut. Das ist nicht so total
übertriebenes Board mit
ähm, Zeug, was du eh nicht brauchst.
Mit 5 Netzwerkadaptern, mit 10G,
mit sonst was. Ich mach da eh ne 10G,
10G, 10G Adapter rein.
Ähm,
Wupp, Wupp, der Moni.
Drei Monate. Big Brain.
Ähm, und das, was da drinnen war,
macht eigentlich einen ganz guten Eindruck. Hier kommt die
Grafikkarte rein. Hier
kommt die, äh, warte mal,
ist das ein Einfach oder ist das ein Vierfach?
Das ist ein Einfach, ne? Ist egal.
Äh, hier kommt die Grafikkarte rein.
Hier kommt die, äh, Netzwerkkarte
rein. Die 10G-Netzwerkkarte
rein. Und was anderes brauche
ich, glaube ich, eh nicht.
Insofern alles, alles top. Passt ja, wunderbar.
Oh, RAM-Riegel. Flop, flop, flop.
32G. Ryzen.
Gut ist. Fertig.
Gehäuse hab ich.
Netzteil hab ich. Ja, dann
werde ich es wahrscheinlich so machen, ja.
Zumal das Board sogar relativ,
relativ vergünstigt. Naja, ne, ist wieder, ja,
geht so. Ähm, was macht, was macht?
Intel eigentlich gerade?
Kommt da, kommt da, äh,
eine 1080 Ti? Ja, aber ich,
ich übertakte ja nix.
Dann ist doch die Stromversorgung jetzt für mich nicht so wild,
oder? Ich mein, wozu?
Echt, ist das,
hat das eine Onboard-10G-Karte? Wenn das eine
Onboard-10G-Karte hat, dann
wird es sich sogar lohnen.
Äh, wo steht's denn hier?
Ah!
Och ja! Ich mein,
das ist zwar
Kupfer, das ist zwar eine
Kupfer-Netzwerkart, äh, es geht grad
aktuell um gar nichts Bestimmtes,
Bimmerboy, sondern einfach nur, was ich mit dem, was ich mit dem
Mainboard kaufen soll. Ähm,
normalerweise
hab ich ja ein bisschen gewisses
Ziel, was ich im Stream machen will,
aber heute hab ich mir gedacht, wir machen einfach das, was
wir sonntags auch machen. Wir schwätzen
ein bisschen, gucken uns ein bisschen YouTube-Zeug an
und ich muss ja eh in eineinhalb Stunden schon wieder
auf. Das war eher so eine spontane
Geschichte. Das ist eigentlich relativ gut.
Wieso warst du eigentlich inaktiv auf YouTube?
Weil mir, weil YouTube eine Kack-Plattform
geworden ist. Es, es laufen
auf YouTube so viele Vollspasten mittlerweile
rum, dass ich immer Anfälle krieg, wenn ich YouTube
aufmache. Deutschland, YouTube,
international auch, aber
Deutschland, YouTube besonders, ja?
Wenn ich Deutschland, YouTube aufmache, die
Startseite, das können wir ja, also wir simulieren
das mal kurz, okay? Wir simulieren
das mal kurz. YouTube Deutschland.
So, was
haben wir denn hier?
Ähm,
ja, den kann man
sich angucken, der ist cool.
Der, der, der, der ist mir sogar
schon mal auf dem Weg zum Südbahnhof über den Weg gelaufen.
Ähm,
was, was, nee, wir müssen
Trending, Trending müssen wir gucken, Trending.
So, Familie entführt.
Dean greift an.
Äh, Greif, Dean greift
an. Ah ja, geil, supergeile
Trends. So, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Die Nintendo Direct.
Okay, ich wusste gar nicht,
dass die die Nintendo Direct haben. Tränen
in den Augen. Sarah Lombardi
singt Pietros neuen Song.
Meine Güte, ähm, ähm,
Bundesliga Challenge, juckt mich auch nicht.
JP Performance. Äh, ich habe einen
auf der, einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit, der guckt
den ganzen Tag,
wenn er nichts zu tun hat, guckt
er diese Autotuning-Dinger.
Ben und Lea küssen
sich. Ich weiß nicht mal, wer
Ben und Lea ist.
Anthony versteckt sich
im Wald gegen...
Das ist doch der, das ist der
Integrationstest, Mann.
Könnt ihr euch noch an dieses,
Integrations-Test-Video erinnern?
Was halt voll gefakt war, wo damals alle gedacht haben,
das wäre, das wäre, das wäre
legit.
Angelo Merte, genau.
Angelo Merte, genau,
der ist das.
So, dann haben wir Semmel vs. Brötchen.
Was einfach mal 834k aufrufert.
Krass Schule.
Da kommt einmal der Lash an Start mit
einer ganzen Folge. Okay, aber
ich meine...
Und es ist...
Und es ist noch schlimmer bei mir.
Die Empfehlungen auf YouTube sind noch schlimmer als das, was wir
jetzt hier sehen.
Zehn Minuten zum
Sixpack. Eats?
Eats. Das mache ich, das mache ich
auch. Auf geht's.
Komm, zeig mal her.
Ich kann...
Nee, kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Tut mir leid, Leute, kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Und bei mir ist die
Empfehlung noch schlimmer,
weil ich bin ja...
auf YouTube quasi immer im Gaming-Bereich
unterwegs und der schlägt mir
permanent Gaming
und funny German
Pranks und...
So ein Stummsinn. Ich kann mir
das nicht mehr angucken. Das heißt, was ich
mittlerweile mache ist, ich benutze
YouTube für Videos
über Firefox und
ich benutze...
Ich gehe nicht auf YouTube.
Ich benutze ansonsten YouTube
immer über Chrome mit einem zweiten Account,
dass ich keine scheiß Empfehlung kriege.
Da kriege ich so gut wie keine deutschen Videos
als Empfehlung und auch nur das, was ich
abonniert habe, was mir gefällt und das halte ich
aus. Den Rest kann ich...
ertrage ich nicht.
So.
Ja, also falls ihr
mein neues Video noch nicht geguckt
habt... Gibt es Leute, die
mein neues Video noch nicht geguckt haben?
Es haben manche geschrieben, es wirkt
für sie wie ein Comedy-Programm.
War jetzt nicht unbedingt
die Absicht. Ich habe mir
zur Abwechslung einfach nur ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben,
ja.
Aber vorher müssen wir mal gucken, ob ich
Fragen übersehen habe.
Guck mal hier. Fragentool.
Was haben wir? Ich würde mir aktuell nichts
Neues kaufen. Habe noch ein i7.
Warte noch, bis neue Grafiker und CPUs
kommen. Was macht denn Intel
so?
Kommt von Intel demnächst was Gescheites?
Streaming-Setup.
Mein Streaming-Setup ist nicht so
spektakulär. Ich habe hier
meinen Einrechner,
wo ich von streame und was ihr jetzt seht, und
zweiten Rechner hier für Stream-Vorschau.
Also, da gibt es nichts großartiges zu sagen.
Von Intel kommt was aber nichts
Gescheites, ok? Ich meine,
Intel hat ja die Chance.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es schaffen, jetzt direkt
architekturmäßig zu
AMD direkt wieder aufzuschließen. Das glaube
ich nicht. Aber, es ist ja
nicht so, als wäre Intel hoffnungslos hinten dran.
Also, da ist ja jetzt
nicht so... Da ist ja im normalen
im normalen Desktop-Segment jetzt nicht irgendwie
Welten zwischen Intel und AMD.
In der Vergangenheit war es halt einfach so,
dass AMD jetzt bessere Angebote hatte. Aber,
wenn Intel jetzt den Kram einfach
billiger macht, wenn Intel
den Kram billiger macht, da gibt es keinen
Grund... Da gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund, warum man nicht Intel
kaufen sollte. Äh, was für eine
Klasse. Ich spiele gerade relativ wenig per
Zuwachs halt, weil ich irgendwie in diese League nicht so richtig reingekommen
bin. War ja auch nicht. Äh, das sind noch Fragen
vom letzten Mal. Kann das sein?
Das ist... Das sind die Fragen von...
vom... vom Sonntag.
Macht er eigentlich Stadia so? Macht er?
Macht er eigentlich Stadia gerade so?
Abkacken wahrscheinlich. Also,
ähm...
Welche Neuerungen kommen... Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Da bin ich gespannt. Habe ich schon mal aufgemacht,
ob der das ein bisschen besser erklären kann, als dieser komische
Blog-Eintrag das letzte Mal.
Beim letzten Mal hast du auch die Fragen vergessen. Ja, aber
die waren in Bezug auf den letzten Stream und ich habe keine Ahnung
mehr, was ich... Oh, 2 und 3 Spiele?
Was ist mit denen los? Wir gucken uns mal den
Anfang an, ob das irgendwie interessant ist.
Wenn nicht, dann skappen wir das einfach.
Das Microsoft-Magazin.
Hallo Leute, herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einem neuen Video hier auf Windows
Area. Und es freut mich, dass du
eingeschaltet hast. Und schon wieder
ist ein halbes Jahr vergangen. Was bedeutet,
dass es Zeit für ein neues... Der hat sich
an, das muss ja gleich loslachen hier.
Und schon wieder ist es ein halbes Jahr.
...Windows-Update ist.
Heute stelle ich euch Windows 10
Version 20.04 vor. Ja, dann, let's go.
Oder einfach das April 2020
Update. Falls sich
jetzt jemand fragt, wieso die Versionsnummer
20.04 lautet, oder man kann es
auch 2004 aussprechen...
Weil es Microsoft
ist. Und
sie ihre eigenen Sachen nicht einhalten.
Ich meine, das ist 2020
04. Ähm...
Es ist nicht 20. April.
Nein, nein, es ist 2020
April. Aber
Microsoft, das ergibt mittlerweile keinen
großartigen Sinn mehr. Ich meine, diesmal schaffen sie es
vielleicht, aber das letzte Mal haben sie es
selbst nicht geschafft einzuhalten.
Das ist die gleiche
Ubuntu-Taktik.
...
Oh, ja, ist gut. Komm.
an der Suche.
Ah, die Windows-Suche, die
nicht richtig funktioniert. Ja, schön, schön.
Angeblich ist die Windows-Suche jetzt neu
und die Windows-Suche,
das habe ich im Vorfeld schon gelesen, die Windows-Suche ist
neu und funktioniert angeblich jetzt viel besser als vorher.
Wobei ich mir dann
immer denke,
wenn ich, im Zweifelsfall,
wenn ich wirklich unter
Windows was suchen will, nehme ich
einfach Grepp.
Ist zwar kein Windows-eigenes Tool,
oder Feind, ja, Feind und Grepp
und gut ist.
Erstmal mit der
Suchindizierung.
Dazu begebe ich nicht einfach...
Das habe ich schon gelesen, das ist neu,
angeblich funktioniert die Suche jetzt gut.
CMDR-Klick, los!
Sucheinstellungen.
Das heißt...
Okay, da sind wir noch bei der Suche.
Let's go.
Kein Wunder, dass das Video 38 Minuten geht.
Wir konnten einfach nur die ersten 10 Minuten
easy skippen.
Oh, der Spielmodus.
Jetzt...
...werden nicht mehr indexiert.
Das ist vor allem sehr gut.
Auch, wenn ihr dem PC-Problem helfen müsst
und ihr merkt, sein PC ist langsam,
dann könnt ihr einfach hier gucken,
ist sein Windows jetzt auf einer schnellen SSD-Festplatte
oder auf einer alten, langsamen HDD-Festplatte.
Excellent.
Und jetzt kommen wirklich meine Lieblingsneuerungen.
Und ich habe lange drauf gewartet und ich bin selber überrascht,
dass sie in Windows integriert wurde.
Hier im Taskmanager.
Das hört schon gleich viel besser an, oder?
Ja.
Und zwar...
...eine Temperaturanzeige für die GPU.
Die sieht man einmal hier in der Schnellübersicht.
5% Auslastung, 50 Grad.
Und auch hier einmal in der Detailübersicht.
Pockers!
Was ich sehr schade finde,
die Anzeige beschränkt sich nur auf die Grafikkarte.
Das heißt, ich sehe natürlich weiterhin keine Temperaturen für die CPU.
Das hat Microsoft leider nicht zu Ende gebracht.
Das finde ich persönlich sehr schade.
Ich hoffe wirklich, das kommt beim nächsten Update.
Am besten schon beim...
...20H2-Update.
Ich weiß gerade nicht, wie die Versionsnummer sein wird, weil...
Oh mein Gott, wir können im Taskmanager die CPU anzeigen lassen.
Äh, die GPU-Temperatur anzeigen lassen.
Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Ich muss gerade mal was nachgucken.
Ich will mal kurz wissen, wie weit mein Server ist.
Und zwar...
Ähm...
Ich habe doch vorhin im letzten Stream erzählt,
dass ich gerade OpenStreetMaps...
Äh, OpenStreetMaps, kann man das kompilieren nennen?
Äh, dass ich gerade OpenStreetMaps...
Wie nennt man das?
Extrahiere.
Ich will mir einen OpenStreetMaps-Server bauen.
Für unser Routenplanungstool da.
Und...
Ähm...
Mal gucken, wie weit der ist.
Wie weit ist er denn?
Der ist immer noch nicht fertig.
WTF.
Der läuft seit 5 Tagen oder so.
Das Ding hat 16 Kerne.
Na okay, 8 mit Hyperthreading.
Die Kiste hat 8 Kerne.
Äh...
24G RAM.
100...
100G Swap auf ne SSD.
Warum braucht das so lang?
Der macht hier auch gar nix.
Haha, Lua.
Ja, das ist so das Extra.
Warum braucht das so lang?
Ich hab da jetzt 2 Tage nicht mehr draufge...
Ne, ne, der hat sich nicht aufgehangen.
Der ist hier 10, 20, 30, 40...
Ich hab vor 2 Tagen draufgeguckt, da hat er noch was anderes gemacht.
Ich glaub nicht, dass der sich aufgehangen hat.
Guck, der macht auch hier was.
Der macht auch hier was.
Okay, ich...
Ich bin wieder weg.
Also hier, ich schlapp mich wieder aus.
So, gucken wir uns hier mal den Taskmanager weiter an.
...Entwicklungsplan ist.
So, und das war's auch schon mit dem Taskmanager.
Sieh leise, oder?
Hab ich eigentlich schon erwähnt, dass dieses Update wirklich kurz ist.
Also, ich glaub die Entwicklungszeit war...
Ja, aber 38 Minuten kann man trotzdem mitfüllen.
...zirka 9 Monate.
Und wir haben wirklich sehr, sehr wenig, aber auch komplett neue...
Oh, was ist das?
...Entwickler bei Microsoft an das...
Wie?
Oh, das, Leute, das wollten wir uns ja auch nochmal angucken im Stream.
Den Windows 10...
Den X-Emulator.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns das wirklich angucken sollen, weil...
Das ist ja das neue...
Dieses neue...
Das zukünftige Windows 10, was für Tablets und Gedöns gedacht ist, wo die Leute jetzt Schiss haben, dass es irgendwann auch auf den Desktop kommt.
Mich erinnert das ja ein bisschen...
Mich erinnert das ja ein bisschen an Windows 8 mit Kacheln, wenn ich ehrlich bin, das Ding.
Jetzt hab ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, das folgende ist, wie gesagt...
Ähm...
Ich hab ja auch ne Liste gemacht.
Mit Themen für die nächsten Streams.
Die gucken wir uns gleich nochmal an.
Ob euch noch ein paar Sachen auffallen.
Äh...
Gaben heute Kommentare im Chat.
Gibt es eigentlich nochmal eine aktuelle...
Aktualisierte Version des Meme-Tools, die auch für Nicht-Broggers benutzbar ist?
Oh ja, ich hoffe irgendwann schon, ja.
Ich hoffe schon.
Ja, weil das, was ich aktuell zusammengebaut hab, das kann ich nicht releasen.
Das ist für'n Arsch.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich bin hier echt fehl am Platz.
Wenn man keine Ahnung von PCs hat.
Ich bin nur wegen der Emotes hier.
Das ist schon jetzt auch schon was, die für jeden...
Für jeden was...
Vielleicht wirst du noch irgendwann zum echten Hackerman.
Das neue System.
Dazu hab ich auch ein Video gemacht.
Das findet ihr jetzt oben rechts, wo ich einmal ne Tour mache.
Durch ne frühe Version von dem System.
Damit zufrieden...
Wenig Leute ihr könnt, die verrückt ist.
So wie es halt bei mir im System ist.
Okay, was gibt's sonst noch?
Ist halt so.
Machen wir dann weiter mit dem Emoji-Panel.
Ähm...
Öffnet sich natürlich jetzt fantastischerweise unten rechts.
Aber ich kann ja ran zum...
Hehe.
Äh...
Muss ich in dem Video immer erwähnen, weil...
Weil das Wissen halt...
Das Emoji-Panel.
Wie macht man das Emoji-Panel aktuell überhaupt auf?
Also mein Emoji-Panel funktioniert aktuell so.
Get Emoji.
Ich geh auf die Seite.
Und kopier mir das Emoji raus, was ich brauche.
Windows plus Punkt.
Ah.
Excellent.
Exquisite Emoji.
Kann man da drin suchen?
Smile.
Moment.
Kann man nicht suchen?
Doch.
Hä?
What the fuck?
What?
Hä?
Wie suche ich da drin?
Sehe ich das richtig, dass die anwenden, dass das kaputt ist?
Excellent.
Einfach tippen.
Okay.
Ich tippe.
Was ist das?
Ist das scheiß wirklich kaputt?
Meine Güte, ey.
Kack-Software.
Ernsthaft, ey.
Guck mal hier, das zeigt auch so komische Sonderzeichen an.
Geh mal in eine Textbox.
Okay, ich bin in einer Textbox.
Punkt.
So.
Test.
Ah.
Excellent.
Ich bin einfach nur zu dumm für sowas.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt quasi sagen...
Jetzt kann ich sagen...
Smile.
Was hat er hier eigentlich durchgestrichen?
Man kann hier das Boomer-Emoji verwenden.
Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Okay.
Wenn man es braucht.
Weiter.
Wirklich sehr wenig Leute.
Ihr könnt dieses Emoji-Panel mit der Tassenkombination wissen.
Und hier wurden neue hinzugefügt.
Das geht jetzt nach Emoji 12 Standard.
Ein paar...
Ach.
Haben die es jetzt auch schon geschafft bei Microsoft?
Ist Unicode 12 nicht schon ein Jahr alt oder so?
Ja.
Ist genau ein Jahr alt.
Ja gut, Microsoft braucht da ein bisschen für.
Kann man ja verstehen.
Die haben zu wenig Geld dafür, ein paar Emojis zu machen.
Das geht nicht.
...Wohl hier durchgeführt.
Außerdem hat man hier auch Kaomojis.
Ein paar neue auch hinzugefügt.
Da habe ich mein Leben lang drauf gewartet.
Ich denke mal, die neuen sind die mit den Smileys.
Und Einstellungen.
Das klingt jetzt unvorbereitet.
Aber andere Sachen drinnen fange ich einmal an.
Mit einer Sache, die ich euch unglaublich gerne zeige.
Oh, es geht.
Oh mein Gott, es geht.
Okay.
Das klingt jetzt unvorbereitet.
Oh mein Gott.
Aber ich kann euch wirklich versprechen, ihr könnt es mir glauben.
Diese Liste war die ganze Zeit weiß.
Ich habe diese Installation seit einer Woche.
Seit einer Woche möchte ich dieses Video machen.
Ich kam bis jetzt noch nicht dazu.
Diese Liste war die ganze Zeit leer und ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ich habe sogar meinen privaten PC aktualisiert und die Liste war ebenfalls leer.
Aber jetzt ist sie persönlich da.
Ich finde es ja geil, wie man so ausrasten kann deswegen.
Aber...
Ich finde es schön, wenn man sich über so etwas freut.
Ich freue mich auch oftmals über kleine Sachen.
Ich bin gerade wirklich dankbar.
Ich weiß nicht, wieso sie da ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Update heute Morgen das gepixt hat.
Oder ob es etwas gebracht hat, dass ich das in den Feedback geschrieben habe.
Der hat gehacksort.
Ich bin gerade glücklich.
Deswegen kann ich euch jetzt zeigen.
Alte Funktionen wurden als optionale Features ausgelagert.
Was sind optionale Features?
Erst einmal zur Verständlichkeit.
Paint.
In Windows sind Sachen integriert.
Paint ist jetzt ein optionales Feature.
Paint Champ.
Hier öffne ich mal das Startmenü.
Gehe zu Zubehör.
Und hier habe ich halt die Standard-Sachen.
Ich meine, ich habe Editor, Paint, Snipping Tool, Windows Media Player, Fax und Scan.
Das kennt man halt.
Paint ist das wichtigste unter Windows.
Und jetzt gibt es in Windows die Möglichkeit, schon seit langem diese Features zu deaktivieren und zu aktivieren.
Das alte Menü sah halt so aus.
Und hier habe ich sogar ein paar erweiterte Features.
Also hier kann ich Internet Explorer deaktivieren und dafür kann ich beispielsweise...
Ja, es ist übrigens geil, dass es immer noch doppelte Menüs gibt.
Windows hat jetzt Dinge wie die Druckverwaltungskonsole deinstallieren oder Editor.
Editor natürlich, das kennt jeder.
Man kann Notepad?
Man kann Notepad deinstallieren?
Das geht aber nicht.
Man kann doch nicht einfach Notepad deinstallieren.
Kann ich erstmalig deinstallieren.
Internet Explorer habe ich schon deinstalliert.
Die Mathematik-Erkennung war, glaube ich, schon beim letzten Update dabei.
Aber Microsoft Paint ist jetzt wirklich neu.
Das heißt, falls jemand von euch nur Paint 3D nutzt, was übrigens ein richtig cooles Programm ist...
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe nicht einmal Paint 3D verwendet bisher.
Ich verwende für so kurze Screenshots Sachen.
Wenn ich einen Screenshot gemacht habe, mache ich immer Paint auf, füge den ein, mache dann irgendwie so und speichere den.
Für alles andere nehme ich Affinity Designer oder Affinity Photo.
...Paint 3D auszuprobieren statt dem alten Paint.
Der kann das jetzt deinstallieren.
Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, ob auch Candy Crush deinstallieren kann.
Wer sagt, ich benutze weder Paint 3D noch das alte Paint.
Ich habe motherfucking GIMP.
Für den ist das auch okay. Einfach weg mit Paint.
Und so weiter.
Auch die PowerShell Easy.
Also ich bin ja, ihr wisst ja, ich bin Linux- und Open Source-Fan.
Aber GIMP kommt mir wirklich nicht in die Tüte.
Oder nicht auf den Rechner drauf.
Nee, Windows-Fax und Scan.
Und das alte WordPad.
Wieso auch immer das existiert.
Es ist auch deinstalliert.
Das Snipping-Tool.
Das Snipping-Tool ist für Noobs.
Allgemein hat Microsoft hier in der...
Groß machen Sachen manuell.
...Stellungenübersicht, also in der neuen Feature-Liste, das Design überarbeitet.
Heißt, ich kann jetzt hier nach Features suchen und das...
Nee, GIMP ist nicht böse.
Ich komme bloß mit GIMP und der Bedienung überhaupt nicht zurecht.
...auch so in der Liste aller Features aus.
Ich kann hier mehrere anwählen.
Und falls ich eins nicht finde, zum Beispiel SSH kann ich...
Oh mein Gott, man kann eine Liste durchsuchen.
...hake ich an und klicke auf Installieren.
Das ist wirklich eine sehr schöne Neuerung.
So, was steht als nächstes auf meiner Liste?
Genau.
Dafür gehen wir...
Ey, man darf nicht vergessen, ne?
Wer jetzt denkt, alter, warum flippt der so aus?
Ich hab's aufs 1,25 Speed.
Also normalerweise flippt der nicht ganz so aus.
Content und Anmeldeoption.
Das ist eine Neuerung.
Die Windows Hello Anmeldung für Microsoft-Konten.
Erforderlich.
Wow.
Das ist eine sehr gute Übersetzung.
Aber zum Glück bin ich ja da und ich kann's euch erklären.
Falls ihr euch in Windows mit eurem Microsoft-Konto eingeloggt habt...
Nein.
...mach ich auch nicht.
Richtig Boomer-Antwort.
Ich weiß.
Aber ich will mich nicht mit meinem Microsoft-Konto einloggen.
...bist bestimmt festgestellt haben, dass das Passwort von eurem...
Ich hab mein Microsoft-Konto verknüpft.
Ja, dass ich Visual Studio und Gedöns aktivieren kann.
Aber zum Login will ich gar nicht kein Microsoft-Konto verwenden.
...Konto auch zu eurem PC-Passwort wird.
Das ist wirklich schrecklich, wenn ihr so wie ich ein 30-stelliges Passwort habt,
weil ihr einfach auf dem Passwortmanager seid.
Alternativ hat man zum Glück noch die Möglichkeit...
Komm, lass 30 stellen.
...Windows-Hello-Login mit...
Das kann ich leider nicht überprüfen, weil...
...Konto geknackt hat...
...indem...
...Windows-Hello...
...kommt ein Update rein und ihr kriegt...
...schnell wieder mit der Arbeit anfangen können.
Das ist das, was ich jetzt auf keinen Fall machen werde.
Kommt da jetzt noch irgendwas...
...irgendwas...
...tolles an neuen Features?
Ich lost forever.
Dann wird er nicht mehr...
...Windows-Einrichtungen...
...viel davon erhalten und zwar eine frische Windows-Installation.
Ihr kennt das bestimmt.
Ihr habt euch ein neues Notebook gekauft und da ist schon von Haus aus viel Software drauf.
Vor allem Mac...
Das stimmt.
Da ist ganz viel Crap drauf.
MacAfee ist einfach Krebs und es ist immer auf einem PC installiert und niemand weiß wieso.
Und das erste, was wir machen...
Ist MacAfee nicht im Knast?
War da nicht irgendwas letztens?
Hier ist der John MacAfee.
Ist der Typ nicht im Knast?
Oder war da nicht irgendwas?
Da war doch irgendwas letztens.
Habe ich doch...
Ja.
Ach der will...
Ach nee, der ist nicht mehr im Knast.
Der will jetzt Präsident werden.
Ah, verstehe.
Was auch immer.
Der Typ...
Der Typ geht ab.
... das MacAfee zu deinstallieren.
Naja, bringt alles nichts.
Mein System ist schon vollgemüllt.
Wer weiß was...
Und dann könnt ihr einmal frisch von neu...
Möchten sie Windows neu installieren?
Ehrlich gesagt?
Nee.
... auf meiner Liste...
...definierte Farbe wählen.
Zum Beispiel...
Oh, jetzt kommt das Killer-Feature.
Ich sehe schon...
Achtung.
... eine optische Sache.
Aber der Funktionsumfang ist weiterhin derselbe.
Mausfarben.
Und unter anderem...
Und unter erleichterte Bedienung kann man erstmalig seinen Textcursor komplett anpassen.
Aber wirklich anpassen, so damit du ihn nie wieder übersiehst.
Nie wieder.
Bahnbrechend.
Okay?
Erstmal kann man natürlich die Breite weiterhin einstellen.
Aber hier oben...
Das übersieht man einfach nicht.
Komplett.
Bahnbrechend.
... Textcursor aktivieren.
Ich habe eine Farbe...
Huge.
... Neonfarbe zur Auswahl.
Ich kann eine benutzerdefinierte Farbe wählen.
Zum Beispiel Orange.
Fantastik.
Und dann kann ich das sogar noch korrigieren.
Ja.
Ich kann es auch ganz dick machen.
Und wenn ich jetzt das Startmenü öffne...
Eieiei.
Ich werde nie wieder den Cursor übersehen, Leute.
Ich bringe euch jetzt in die Bildschirmlupe.
Na?
Wer kennt nicht die Bildschirmlupe?
Oh.
Fuck.
Da.
Das ist die Bildschirmlupe.
Neuigkeit Nummer 1.
Es gibt nicht mehr die minimierte Ansicht mit der Lupe.
Kennt ihr das?
Wenn ihr das...
Sag mal, kann es sein, dass es in Windows 10 Updates keine nennenswerten neuen Features
gibt?
Oh, es geht noch weiter.
Kurz in den Einstellungen.
Unter Personalisierung.
Farben.
Die Farbe zu dunkel.
Und ihr seht...
Die Bildschirmlupe muss jetzt auch im dunklen Design.
Ironischerweise mit einem weißen Fensterrahmen und der Fensterrahmen ist fast genauso groß
wie die Bildschirmlupe.
Ja gut, dass es Microsoft nicht so mit einheitlichem Design hat, das haben wir schon gelernt.
Das ist jetzt also nichts Neues.
Das sieht immer so unfertig aus alles.
Das sieht alles immer so unfertig aus, was die da fabrizieren.
Ob das jetzt so sinnvoll war, sei dahingestellt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall löblich, dass es jetzt im dunklen Design existiert.
Und es skaliert besser auf höheren Bildschirmauflösungen.
Zudem, eine Neuerung.
Die Bildschirmlupe kann jetzt vorlesen.
Inhalte.
Dazu habe ich in den Einstellungen einmal die Möglichkeit...
Oh, Microsoft Stefan.
Und die Stimme.
Und dann...
Was?
Moment.
Was war das andere?
Microsoft Stefan und was?
Microsoft Header?
Stimmt, der Header, Alter.
Was?
Was ist das für ein Name?
Die Stimme.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie sich Microsoft Header anhört.
Header.
Habe ich den vielleicht hier auch drauf?
Speak.
Wie lässt man sich von Windows was vorlesen?
Narrator.
George.
Oh, ne.
Hier.
Wo ist...
Header.
Da ist er.
Ich kann Header einstellen.
Und wie kann ich den Header einstellen?
Da ist er.
Wie kann ich mir jetzt was vorlesen lassen?
Windows Taste und Plus.
Ne, kann ich nix vorlesen lassen.
Ich weiss gar nicht, wie ich mir was vorlesen lasse unter Windows, ehrlich gesagt.
Weiss das jemand.
Wie?
Nein, das ist die neue Vorlesefunktion in seinem Video.
Ich hab da noch nicht den neuen Patch.
Was?
Wie lass ich denn was vorlesen?
Text to Speech.
Text?
Speech, Speech, Speech.
Ich hab doch, ich hab doch Header.
You have selected Microsoft David as the default voice.
Ah, jetzt Header, Header, Header.
Sie haben Microsoft Header als Standardstimme ausgewählt.
Ach, das ist eine Frau. Header.
You have selected Microsoft David as the default voice.
Sie haben Microsoft Stefan als Standardstimme ausgewählt.
Sie haben Microsoft Header als Standardstimme ausgewählt.
Ah, excellent.
Microsoft Header haben wir jetzt als Standardstimme.
Die wollte ich schon immer haben.
Das beste Text-to-Speech ist immer noch...
Korea Text-to-Speech ist das beste Text-to-Speech.
Da kann Microsoft Header einpacken.
Den 360 No-Scrop, den haben wir ja auch noch irgendwo, ja?
Play.
Ich kann mir jetzt beispielsweise...
Seite raussuchen.
Zum Beispiel, abgehakt.
So, Albert's Bananensammlung, ich kann jetzt...
So, das setzt man auf einen echten Linux-Körner.
Ah ja, ähm...
Haben wir uns WSL 2 schon mal angeguckt im Stream?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
In dem Preview, im Preview haben wir uns glaube ich angeguckt.
Haben wir uns WSL 2 schon mal angeguckt?
Wenn nicht, müssen wir das Ganze nochmal machen.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es auch nur minimal besser.
Es geht nichts um einen ordentlichen Linux, vor allem wenn man einen Linux braucht.
So.
Das Windows-Subsystem für Linux ist nun in der Version 2 vorzufinden.
Es ist realisiert in Hyper-V.
Bevor jemand fragt, nein, ihr könnt parallel dazu nicht VMware nutzen.
Zweite Sache, ihr müsst...
Warum nicht?
Warum kann ich dazu nicht parallel VMware benutzen?
Klar geht das.
Habe ich doch auch laufen.
Ihr müsst nicht unbedingt WSL 2 nutzen, ihr könnt auch weiterhin auf WSL 1 setzen.
Weitere Informationen...
Klar geht VMware parallel.
Ich hatte selbst schon WSL auf und nebenbei ein Linux-VM laufen, kein Problem.
Wir sind hier in der Dokumentation von Microsoft.
Die IOPer kann jetzt auf Docker ausgeführt werden.
Bevor jemand fragt, ich nehme eigentlich ihr Geld.
Eine Leichtphase hat am Teil eine neue Stellung.
Ich muss neu klicken.
Okay, waren wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig huge neue Features für Windows.
Kajus?
Ähm, das...
Gut, gut, dass wir uns...
Er meint den VMware Hypervisor.
Hä?
Ich meine, es ist...
Ich kann ESX eh nicht unter Windows laufen lassen.
Ich kann VMware Workstation unter Windows laufen lassen.
Das funktioniert auch parallel zu WSL.
Vielleicht habe ich einfach nicht kapiert, was er gemeint hat.
Aber was haben wir denn sonst noch?
So, wir gucken jetzt ein bisschen Battlefield.
Das haben wir nämlich noch nicht geguckt.
Das beste TTS ist Prime von Steam Labs.
Schau dir Battlefield-Videos an.
Ja, wir gucken jetzt.
Wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays.
Die kam nämlich letzten Sonntag oder so raus, aber zu spät.
Da war ich schon oft mit dem Stream.
Wir wollten das letzte Woche Sonntag im Stream gucken, aber gab's nicht.
Und danach habe ich mir noch ein Video gespeichert, was wir uns angucken müssen.
Und zwar, ähm, ich habe mal wieder ein Video gefunden von einem, der erzählt, dass Linux wunderbar zum Spielen taugt.
Da muss ich dann ein bisschen rumflamen, dass es nicht so ist.
Oder aber, er stellt das Ganze realistisch dar.
Dann flame ich natürlich nicht rum.
Ich flame ja nicht des Flamens wegen irgendwie rum.
Wir gucken uns das Battlefield-Video an und dann, für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, gucken wir uns nochmal mein neues Video an.
Bam.
Oh, schönes Rennen.
Die haben aber, die hatten aber auch keinen Bock, den Heli zu bewegen, oder, die zwei?
Heute haben wir ein episches Video von Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 Top Plays.
Wir haben mit diesem verrückten Klick angefangen.
Der erste Klick von Spank Recon, der drei Töne rauskriegt.
Was? Spank? Spank Recon?
Habe ich das richtig gehört?
Das waren die Noobs im Heli.
Ja, die fliegen auch 2020 noch, die Noobs.
Den Heli.
Oh, das war eine schöne TV-Messe.
... und ein paar Passagiere.
Und dieser Klick von Dave Rajan.
Wow.
Ist das Xbox?
Nee, das ist PC.
Das ist PC.
Schlechter Bitrate.
Das ist ein klassischer Battlefield-3-Moment.
Weiter geht's.
Es ist Pinhead 3001, der Start eines Spiels auf Silk Road.
Er bekommt diesen seltsamen Lag, den man oft auf Battlefield 4 bekommt.
Das ist aber PS4.
Wow, was geht mit dem Panzer ab?
Was zum Geier geht mit dem Panzer ab?
Oh, bäh.
Aber das war Glück.
Das war Glück.
Dominator 666 ist zurück mit einem unglaublichen Sniper-Klick.
Ein Viper.
In der Distanz.
Casually sniping out the pilot, as he did in a similar clip the other week.
But in this one, he also...
Und das war auch gewollt.
Das war auch gewollt.
Ich meine, es hätte genauso gut nicht treffen können, wenn der Heli-Mann ein bisschen anders geflogen wäre.
Aber das war gezielt predicted und er wollte den treffen.
Das war nicht so ein random Schuss irgendwo in den Himmel und hat getroffen.
... second snipe on the remaining gunner in the same Viper.
Awesome stuff.
Three clips sent in from Sugar Maester.
They're all these weird...
Was ist denn das für eine Map?
Das ist Battlefield 4.
Ach, das ist...
Ist das Damm?
Lang... Langkamm... Lang... Dings... Damm?
Only in Battlefield clips you sometimes get on Battlefield 4.
The first, he somehow manages to blow up his own jet as he tries some sort of a rendezvous.
No matter though, he can still take out his targets from the ground.
Ach, das ist die Remake.
Jeder weiß gar nicht, welche das ist.
...
The second is from the side of his chopper as he jumps into the...
Dragon Valley, ah. Dragon Valley, ah.
...
...and shoots a jet, diving to the side of him.
Das ist nice, wenn sowas klappt.
...a long-range RPG, on Golemed Railway.
Das war auch cool.
...
...Was? Was ist denn mit dem los?
Soll ich das mal anpassen?
Der... Der ist... Der ist kurz... Der...
Der... Sauerstoffmangel.
...
... What?
... it's the Revenant.
He's going to be playing on Battlefield 4 Hainan Resort.
...
Oh, das ist Konsolen-Auflösung.
Der fliegt jetzt davor, ne?
Der fliegt jetzt...
Ja!
Oh!
Wie das?
Das war eine nice TV-Missile.
Die haben Hex, warum sollten die Hex haben?
Das war wirklich...
Also, ich glaube ihm diesmal sogar, dass das wirklich prediktet war.
Ich meine, der wusste ja, dass er ein Looping macht und es könnte durchaus sein, dass es hittet.
Ich meine, es war natürlich auch Glück dabei, bei all solchen Sachen.
Das ist Langkardam jetzt, ne?
What?
What the fuck?
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Absolutely incredibly lucky.
Never seen anything quite like this, when you didn't even mean to.
And they managed to take out an enemy jet.
Man hat es nicht richtig gesehen, aber da ist gerade ein Jet drüber geflogen.
Das ist nice.
We hit the jet.
Here we go.
Jetzt feiern sie sich ab, ey.
You might have seen this clip on Twitter.
I did post it around a week ago.
Moment, Leute.
Ist das Hardline?
Das sieht aus wie Hardline.
Auf der PS4.
Wahrscheinlich noch ein halbvoller Server am Start.
Is Yuoshi?
Probably butchered that name.
Middlefinger sent to the Scout Chopper.
No scopes it out with the M1903 and then proceeds to steal.
The Scout Chopper, or the Little Bird, or whatever you want to call it.
The ultimate Hardline-Clip.
Next we have a selection of clips sent in from Parallax.
I'm gonna let these ones run in the background with some Battlefield 4-themed music.
They're really awesome stuff.
The sort of thing that you will see in a montage, but also well worthy of being in the Battlefield-Topplay.
Starting out with that incredible long-range Ronde-Zug.
Enjoy.
Oh, so Sachen sind immer cool.
So Sachen sind immer sehr nice.
Es ist immer eine Portion Glück bei, klar, es gehört auch Übung dazu, aber das ist immer nice zu sehen.
Sag mal, Chat, lebt ihr noch?
Ja.
Ah, ich hab Glück.
Hab ich aber Glück gehabt.
Kappa, eins, zwei, drei.
Oh, na das war Glück
Er wollte den anderen hitten
Ich hab mal
Ein Pro, das muss ich mal nachmachen
Ich hab mal einen Battlefield 3 damals
Ich nenn mal einen Pro
Chatpilot
Gesehen, am Controller damals
Also Pro, im Falle vom Geldverdienen
Natürlich nicht, aber einer der besten
Chattypen, die es damals gegeben hat
Auf der Konsole
Und
Das hat sich ungefähr so angehört
Mit dem Controller in der Hand
Weil du musstest ja
Du musstest ja im Battlefield 3 die Geschwindigkeit optimal halten
Und das hat sich ungefähr so angehört
Wie der geflogen ist
Das war sein Beschleunigungsding vom Flugzeug
Da wäre mir der Finger abgefallen
Das ging 20 Minuten
Das ging die komplette Runde
Ging das so
Optimalen Speed halten im Chat
Controller ASMR
Ganz genau
Guck dir lieber Corona-Chan-Infektio-ASMR an
Und um von diesen Clips von Parallax zu folgen
hat Viola Elfie auch in 4 wirklich tolle Clips
Da hatten wir heute ein bisschen viele
Flugzeug-Stellclips
Ich lasse diese in der Hintergrund
mit etwas Battlefield-Themed-Musik
Wirklich tolle Dinge
Es macht mich, dass ich zurück möchte
Und ein Löffel dieser Maps auf BF4 wiederholen
Ein Spiel, das ich über 2000 Stunden in
Einfach auf PC
Und ich möchte es immer noch zurück spielen
Das sagt alles
Die Hexe hat letztens erzählt
Er hat kein Team, aber er hat ein Team
Er ist Papa
Ich hab't BorderLörse
Entweder nur Hacker am Start oder Server leer
Hey Max, gibst du eigentlich auch Advice bei technischen Problemen?
Ja, aber
Also erstens
Ohne Gewehr
Ich bin nicht daran schuld, wenn etwas kaputt geht
Und zweitens je nach Problem kann ich einfach nichts zu sagen
Aber du kannst, schieß mal los
Hau rein, in den Chat
Rein Eliminieren
Das ist nicht mehr im Trend, Ne
Das war ja mal lange Zeit auf YouTube so angesagt, dass man irgendwas rein-eliminiert hat.
Das ist heute, das ist nicht mehr.
Das ist ziemlich 2014.
Oh, das war hier clean as fuck.
Richtig nice.
Geht sowas in Battlefield 5 eigentlich auch?
Kann man in Battlefield 5 aussteigen aus dem Jet, rum durch die Luft fliegen, Panzerfausten dabei und wieder einsteigen?
Wenn ich laufe aus Battlefield 5, habe ich das noch nie gesehen.
Leider nicht.
Oh, das ist ja blöd.
Jawoll.
Was? To finish episode?
Die Zeit ist erst zur Hälfte rum.
Ich habe das hier von Scream gespielt. Er spielt auf Operation Metro Battlefield 3, geht auf einer riesigen Killingstrecke mit dem M249.
Es ist toll, dass Scream Battlefield 3 spielt, weil er es nicht weiß, wie er es macht.
Er kann nur allein bleiben für den längsten Zeitpunkt.
In einem Spiel, in dem oft Leute um die Körner gehen, muss man mit Spielern, die rumlaufen, und mit Räumen, die nicht gut sind, und mit all dem.
Das ist oft ein neues Spiel.
Aber es war besonders bad, trotz des tollen Spiels.
Er macht es so, dass es sich um die Körner handelt.
top plays machen die kommen am wochenende ich habe jetzt ja gerade ein
video aufgenommen gestern aber vorgestern gestern hochgeladen
ich mache wahrscheinlich morgen eins wo ich mich noch mal über die ganze
homeoffice geschichte und leute die sie gebacken kriegen auslassen muss und am
samstag oder sonntag kommt das battlefield video
die 18 18 klatscht rein man kann man kann ohne probleme 200 fps haben im
battlefield 4 er wird er wird ja auch nicht das ist
jetzt ist jetzt epilepsie warnung bild hier der das hatte das hatte man damals
schon wenn man die qualität nicht ganz auf max gestellt hat
und ich habe das gefühl dass battlefield ein spiel ist was richtig von vielen fps
profitieren
das fühlt sich einfach ein battlefield fühlt sich mit 200 fps einfach doppelt
so gut an wie mit 60
bis heute eines meiner lieblingsmaps wobei ich ja sagen muss meine lieblings
rush map im battlefield 3 ist immer noch terran highway komplett underrated map
erwähnt niemand
wenn es um top maps geht aber ich finde terran highway ist richtig gute gute
rush map von der abwechslung her du hast die panzer base action am anfang dann
geht es runter die straße ein bisschen in die häuser kampfzone rein und dann
den highway hoch in die end an die endbasis terran highway fand ich habe ich
immer extrem gerne gespielt natürlich so die klassiker hier bazaar demmerwein
peak und so sind auch geil aber ich muss sagen terran highway ist persönlich meine
lieblings rush map aus battlefield 3 wohlgemerkt
meine lieblings rush map insgesamt würde ich sagen das ist so ein bisschen das
ist schwierig also waldparaiso ist nicht waldparaiso port valders ist auf jeden
fall weit vorne wobei port valders ein bisschen eklige choke points hatte oder
ansonsten sehr also die ganzen bad company 2 maps und teilweise auch bad
company 1 sind extrem geile rush maps aus battlefield 3 würde ich aber sagen terran highway und halt natürlich auch
bazaar und demmerwein peak und sand crossing und so die battlefield 3 hatte
schon auch sau viele geile rush maps wobei ich ja sagen muss dass gerade
firestorm und caspian border überhaupt nicht mein fall waren
da waren total viele geil drauf weil halt panzer action und flugzeug action
aber ich war halt kein flugzeugmann im battlefield 3 deswegen fand ich caspian border und border und firestorm gar nicht so toll
auf jedem point da so was abhineee
ok
wie oft wie oft
man hier die Gegner im Spawn hatte, ne?
Wie oft man hier die Gegner
im Spawn hatte. Die Spawnpunkte
in Battlefield 3 waren nun wirklich auch nicht alle geil.
Also das ist schon...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Topplay ist.
Also jetzt. Der erste Teil war schon nice.
Aber das hier, ich mein,
da hab ich auch teilweise
5 Minuten am Stück einfach
nur an der Ecke gelegen und alles weggeschnetzelt.
Und da lagen, genau
wie hier, lagen so viele Gegner,
die noch auf Respawn-Timer
gewartet haben, dass du gar nicht wusstest, es ist jetzt ein
Gegner oder ist es noch eine Leiche, die in den Respawn ist.
Dann auch noch meine
Lieblingswaffe aus Battlefield 3.
Oh.
Was ist...
Was ist das für eine Waffe?
Die hab ich, glaube ich, nicht einmal ausgerüstet,
die Waffe.
Sniper.
Nicht einmal ausgerüstet.
Oh, aber cool.
Ja, da macht die ganz schön platt.
Cooler Clip ist es, auf jeden Fall.
Was zur Hoffnung hast du
für Bad Company 3?
Naja, die größte Hoffnung, die ich für Bad Company 3 habe,
ist, dass es erstmal rauskommt.
Weil angeblich ist es ja gar nicht mehr in Entwicklung.
Aber, wie gesagt, Gerüchte
über Gerüchte, da kann man ja nichts drauf geben.
Aber es wurde ja weder offiziell bestätigt,
noch irgendwas dazu gesagt.
Also man kann eigentlich nur hoffen,
dass es überhaupt...
äh...
mal irgendwann rankommt.
Bombi!
Bad Company 3, wenn das...
Ich glaub's erst, wenn ich sehe,
Bad Company 3.
Nee, dieses Jahr kommt kein neues Battlefield.
Ein neues Battlefield kommt wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr.
Und dann mal gucken.
Und dann müssen sie langsam aber sicher...
Nee, müssen sie nicht, weil
Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 haben sich ja sogar ganz gut verkauft.
Das ist ja nicht so, als wäre das jetzt
der totale Reinfall gewesen.
Ist es ja gar nicht mal.
Ähm, die müssen eigentlich gar nichts, was ich sag, machen.
Leider.
Hehehe.
Und der zweite Clip, den er mitgebracht hat, ist auf...
...Floodzone, mit der AEK.
Ein bisschen ein anderer Clip, dieser hier.
Es ist mehr so ein PTFO-Clip, weil er versucht,
die Objekte auf Rush zu erreichen.
Es ist sehr ungewöhnlich, dass ich einen
Floodzone-Rush-Clip mitgebracht habe, aber einen wirklich tollen.
Also genießt diesen ein bisschen ungewöhnlichen Clip,
den ihr auf Battlefield 4 oft nicht sehen werdet.
Was?
Wo?
Hat der, hat der gerade eine Granate bei sich von Fuß beschmissen?
Nee, das war ein Medpack, Medpack, ne?
Das Aim war aber ziemlich on point,
die letzten paar Gegner.
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Oh, noch die Legehähne gemacht.
So gehört sich das.
Eine richtig nice Legehähne.
Die Gegner! Die Gegner!
Please!
Gegner!
Es, es, es schmerzt!
Wenn das Absicht war,
dass er sich einen Schuss übrig gelassen hat
bei der AEK zum schneller Nachladen,
dann war das der, der massivste
Big-Brain-Play, den ich heute gesehen habe.
Sato's next.
This is Battlefield 4 Operation Locker.
Smoke everywhere. Having to make use
of a few spotted enemies with this
ACE-23. A really nice back
range, though, as he flanks around the side here,
and the enemy team are all bunched up.
All together.
Der spielt bestimmt gerade aus der Quarantäne.
Warte Zeit.
Oh.
The second club you sent in is once again
on Battlefield 4 Operation Locker.
In your face.
How many people did you see using the mayor's leg for a top play?
Three kills to start us off.
Ich wusste nicht mal, dass die Waffe überhaupt so heißt.
Die Gegner!
Please! Gegner!
Ihr macht mich fertig!
Was ist mit euch los?
Die Gegner sind wieder so hohl.
Also, es ist nicht, dass er schlecht
spielen würde, oder so.
Ich mein, die Snipes sind übel nice,
aber die Gegner...
Also, so gut er spielt,
so gut müssen die Gegner
auch mitspielen, dass das funktioniert.
Wenn du Shotgun spielst, wirst du gleich geflamed
nach der ersten Runde.
Fuck Shotgun!
Die Range, ja.
Naja, die ist aber auch nicht so hundertprozentig
zuverlässig.
Haha!
Der hat sich das auch nicht so gedacht.
Guck, also, das sind ja immer nicht...
Das ist das, warum ich nie gerne Shotgun
gespielt habe in Battlefield,
weil die Dinger so zu
90% one-hitten und ab und zu
rechnest du nicht, damit nur so überlebt einer.
SaitoTV, schick her!
Aber nur, wenn's gut ist.
Hahaha!
Die checken wieder nix!
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen,
dass es da so viele
Noobs noch gibt in dem Spiel.
Ich mein, die hatten jetzt wie lange?
Sieben Jahre Zeit, oder so?
Nee, nicht ganz.
Sechs Jahre Zeit?
Nicht mehr Noobs zu sein?
Richtiges NA-Aim von den Gegnern,
ja.
Hoho! Was ne Range!
Hab das gesehen!
Was?
Was ne Rage am Ende
mit der Shotgun!
Da machen ja manche Sniper schon keinen
one-hit mehr auf die Entfernung, wo der gerade
mit der Shotgun one-hitted hat.
Ein nices Video wieder.
Aber nicht schlägt...
Enemy AC-130 im Buff.
Das stimmt!
Das ist immer noch der beste Ansager!
Das brauchen wir eigentlich fast im Memeboard schon, oder?
Was sagt ihr dazu, Leute?
Egal!
Auf jeden!
Gut, mach ich rein.
Tango Sucker, genau!
Tango Sucker!
What?
Oh, das ist mein Video!
Ich krieg mein eigenes Video-App vor!
Oh...
So, jetzt will uns...
Ach ja, ähm...
Frage an euch!
Wollen wir jetzt eigentlich noch zusammen
mein letztes Video angucken, oder nicht?
Dein Pfaffkott?
Schwer zu sagen.
Ich würd sagen...
Ich würd sagen Black Ops 1.
Black Ops 1
hatte, finde ich, das beste Gesamtpaket.
MW2 war auch
cool, wobei ich sagen muss aus heutiger Sicht,
der MW2-Multiplayer war der Anfang
vom Ende im Endeffekt.
Ähm...
Was schnell sterben und random Tode
und so angeht.
Da fand ich Black Ops 1 schon deutlich besser.
MW2 hatte aber auf jeden Fall coole Sachen.
Ich weiß noch, wie nice die Spec Ops Missionen
mit dem Friseur zusammen waren.
Ähm...
Diese Koop-Spec Ops Mission.
Die haben ultra Bock gemacht.
Einmal nur.
Koop mit jemandem zusammen.
Ähm...
Mein Lieblings-Battlefield.
Oh...
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Für sich genommen sind Bad Company 1, 2,
Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 nice Games.
Ähm...
Ich würd sagen Battlefield 3.
Wobei...
Wobei Bad Company 1 und vor allem Bad Company 2
auch extrem geil waren.
Ich würd das sogar eher auf...
Ja doch, doch.
Rein von dem, wie viel Zeit ich reingesteckt hab und
wie viel ich gespielt hab und auch was ich alles gemacht hab.
Dann doch Battlefield 3.
Okay.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal...
Guck mal.
Ich krieg sogar Highlight,
weil Corona im Titel vorkommt.
Weil Corona im Titel vorkommt,
krieg ich sogar angezeigt.
Hier unter meinem Video.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen, ich mag...
Viel zu leise. Max du bist viel zu leise.
Warum bist du so leise?
Was soll das?
Hallo Jungs und Mädels. Hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen,
ich mag...
Max du bist immer noch so leise.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal mein...
Mein eigenes Video.
Ähm...
Für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels. Hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen,
ich mag Corona.
Da fühl ich mich echt so ganz...
Jetzt Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
Ja, es haben viele geschrieben,
das wirkt für sie wie ein Comedy-Programm.
Das war überhaupt nicht so gedacht.
Ich hab mir nur ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Vorher.
Was ich sagen will.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen,
ich mag Corona.
Da fühl ich mich echt so ganz wie daheim.
Wunderbar.
Aktuell muss sich Deutschland mit einem Thema beschäftigen,
was ganz viele Leute zu schaffen macht.
Nämlich soziale Distanz.
Das ist eine Wortkreation,
von der ich gar nicht wusste, dass die überhaupt existiert.
Bis vor ein paar Tagen.
Die ist das ja in aller Munde.
Soziale Distanz, Kontaktverbot, Kontaktsperre
und damit haben richtig viele Leute
ganz, ganz schwierig.
Also für die ist das ganz schwer und haben ganz viele Probleme.
Ich mein, das ist natürlich ein Thema,
mit dem wir als Gamer und echte Hackermans
natürlich bestens vertraut sind.
Auch ganz ohne Corona.
Aber für die normalen Casuals
und Leute ist das echt ein Problem.
Die wissen nicht, was sie machen sollen.
So ohne andere Menschen
und teilweise auch mit weniger Sonnenlicht
und solchen Sachen. Ja.
Ich hab bei mir was umgedreht.
Ich hab mich die letzten Jahre eher gefragt,
Scheiße, was mach ich denn mit anderen Menschen zusammen?
Bei mir liegt es einfach daran,
ich mag andere Menschen nicht.
Natürlich meine YouTube-Subs und Twitch-Subs
selbstverständlich ausgenommen.
Weil Schleim, Schleim und so.
Da können wir eigentlich nur drüber lachen.
Das ist für mich so wunderbar.
Nein, das ist nicht live.
Das ist mein letztes Video.
Ich verstehe, dass es ein wenig verwirrend ist.
Wie findest du eigentlich deine G513?
Ich hab keine G513, ich hab eine G403.
So wie es mir geht.
Nur halt gezwungenermaßen.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema
andere Menschen sind.
Vor ein paar Tagen, also als die ganze
Corona-Geschichte schon in vollem Gange war
und auch schon offizielle Meldungen raus waren,
die Leute sollen ein bisschen Abstand halten,
nicht so viele Leute, nicht so viele Gruppen,
also nicht so viele Leute auf engem Raum
in Gruppen zusammen,
bin ich am Main lang gelaufen zum Rewe.
Bei uns beim Rewe ist ja
Einkaufen gehen ist ja mittlerweile auch schon
abenteuerlich geworden, das Ganze.
Deswegen, ich mach's wie bisher.
Ich bestell das meiste aus dem Internet.
Das ist ja auch was, was für viele absoluten
Den hab ich doch schön zusammenge...
Ich wollte gerade sagen gefotoshoppt,
aber es ist nicht wirklich gefotoshoppt.
Den hab ich doch schön zusammengebaut,
den Boomer und den Apple CRT Monitor, oder?
Twitch React auf eigenes Video.
Huge Six Head.
Neuland mittlerweile ist,
wie man kann im Internet bestellen.
Was, man kann sogar Klopapier im Internet bestellen?
Oh, das hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht.
Es ist unglaublich, wie überrascht
manche Leute über solche Sachen sind,
dass das tatsächlich möglich ist.
Zumindest, ich bin am Main lang gelaufen zum Rewe,
ne, erstmal an der Kneipe vorbeigelaufen,
sitzen da Leute drin, keine Ahnung,
5, 6, 7, 8 Leute,
20 cm Abstand, besaufen sich.
Ja, ist vielleicht keine allzu gute Idee.
Danach kam ich in ein Familienhaus
und entgegen mit drei Pärchen...
Oh, viel zu laut, viel zu laut eigentlich
der Sound, den ich reingemacht habe.
Fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Aber,
Kinderwagen, Kinder,
bestimmt auch 15 Leute oder so.
Hat keinem was gejuckt.
Danach am Main
auf einer Decke
an die 20 Leute auf einer
riesen Decke Picknick gemacht, so richtig YOLO,
juckt uns alles nicht.
Das habe ich ja sogar noch auf Twitter geschrieben,
die Leute, die ich beim Picknick erwischt habe.
Am Main.
Also, was man daran wieder sieht ist,
wenn man sich darauf verlassen muss,
auf andere Leute, dann ist man
komplett verlassen. In Italien kriegen sie es jetzt
mittlerweile auch halbwegs hin.
Da sitzen sie auf dem Balkon und singen zusammen.
Bei uns juckt das noch nicht so viele Leute.
Am besten gehen die
danach noch abends zur Oma essen
und wundern sich hoch, warum hustet die Oma
auf einmal. Ja, woran könnte das nur liegen?
Gut, das dauert ja meistens ein bisschen
länger, aber das ist den Leuten dann wahrscheinlich
vollkommen unerklärlich, wie von uns.
Von uns können die das ja gar nicht haben.
Da lade ich echt drauf.
Wobei, mittlerweile singen wir ja auch.
Es ging vor ein paar Tagen ja über die ganzen Social Networks.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Auf Twitter?
Oder an die Freude?
Hashtag?
Das war so schrecklich teilweise, die Leute.
Da haben welche gesungen,
haben Trompete gespielt
und Geige gespielt und das war so
unglaublich schäpp
alles. Spielst du gerade
deinen YouTube-Video? Ja.
Ich spiele gerade meinen YouTube-Video, aber das haben noch nicht alle gesehen.
Dass wir jetzt auch
ohne an die Freude gesungen haben.
Leute haben am Fenster teilweise sehr schäpp
ohne an die Freude gesungen.
Ob sich das Schiller und Beethoven so gedacht haben, weiß ich nicht.
Was mich ja persönlich gewundert hat,
ist, dass wir
ohne an die Freude gesungen haben und nicht
Helene Fischer atemlos oder sowas.
Damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt...
Ich muss sagen, das war ein guter Witz.
Zumal das auch ganz gut zum Thema
Lungenentzündung passt.
Sowohl vom Text her, als auch vor allem von der Musik her.
Es gab
auf Twitter, wie gesagt, zig Videos, wo die Leute
zusammen am Fenster gestanden haben
und zusammen Musik gemacht haben.
Und Fenster ist ja auch ein gutes Thema,
weil am Anfang
bei dieser ganzen Corona-Geschichte
ging ja so das Gerücht um,
Bill Gates ist dran schuld.
Bill Gates hätte ja schon irgendwie ein Mittel dagegen
und will das jetzt verbreiten.
Was auch immer man sich da wieder zusammen
fantasiert hat.
Zum Thema Verschwörungstheorien komme ich gleich noch.
Das Video hat was von Stand-Up-Comedy.
Ja, haben viele geschrieben.
Dabei war das überhaupt nicht so geplant.
Ich habe mir halt im Vorfeld was aufgeschrieben dazu.
Tolle neue Entwicklung.
Ähm, aber
als ich mir dann so gedacht habe, Bill Gates?
Wie kommt ihr auf Bill Gates?
Ausgerechnet Bill Gates?
Und da habe ich mal auf YouTube geguckt.
Bill Gates hat tatsächlich vor...
Das war ja wirklich
verschwörungsmäßig.
Bill Gates ist dran schuld.
Wie kommt man echt ausgerechnet auf Bill Gates?
Das ist eine der Millionäre,
Milliardäre,
die ausgesprochen viel
für die Allgemeinheit machen.
Ähm,
dass ausgerechnet Bill Gates
dran schuld ist, weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Irgendwie...
Das ist hart Illuminati.
Ich glaube vier oder fünf
Jahren mal einen Talk gehalten
auf irgendeiner Konferenz.
Zum Thema Epidemien
und Viren und sowas.
Und außerdem hat Windows 95
dieses Jahr
25 Jahre das Jubiläum.
Also wenn das nicht genug Beweis dafür ist,
dass Bill Gates...
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen uns Windows 95 installieren, oder?
Ähm, wann ist das? Im April oder so?
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Langsam ergibt alles Sinn, Leute.
Ja, was gibt es denn sonst noch so Schönes?
Genau, also auf Twitter werden wieder
Gehirnzellen verbrannt.
Und zwar kennt ihr schon die Corona-Challenge.
Also, ihr müsst jetzt nicht nachgucken.
Lasst es lieber bleiben. Ich erzähle euch, was die Corona-Challenge ist.
Und zwar gibt es ein paar Leute,
die finden sich wahnsinnig geil,
wenn sie öffentlich Türklinken ablecken
oder Rolltreppen ablecken oder Klodeckel ablecken.
Alter.
So bescheuert musst du erstmal sein.
Das klingt jetzt so, als hätte ich mir das ausgedacht.
Aber das ist wirklich so.
Das läuft unter dem Hashtag Corona-Challenge.
Die einzige Hoffnung,
die es aus meiner Sicht für diese Leute
noch gibt, ist,
dass sie sich wirklich Corona holen
und dass vielleicht die Chance besteht,
dass sich Coronaviren irgendwie insgeheim
noch in Gehirnzellen umwandeln können.
Ansonsten sehe ich schwarz.
Ansonsten kommen die Leute wohl nie wieder auf den grünen Zweig,
wenn so etwas bescheuertes macht.
Wisst ihr, worüber ich auch...
Lachen über eigene Gags
ist tatsächlich fast schon Pains-Champ.
Ich habe gerade mal
wirklich ziemlich lachen musste.
Wo ich mich echt drüber kaputtgelacht habe.
Und zwar bei der Meldung,
dass die Schulen versuchen,
Online-Unterricht zu machen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, was?
In Deutschland?
Mit welcher Infrastruktur?
Mit welchem Personal?
Da wäre es ja sinnvoller,
hätten die einfach nur einen Overhead-Projektor
mit 70 Millionen Watt und würden das irgendwie
an den Himmel werfen, so Batman-Style.
Das würde besser funktionieren,
als Online-Unterricht zu machen.
Den Gag habe ich ein bisschen geklaut
bei der einen Resitas-Verarsche.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie die das Ganze hinbekommen sollen.
Naja, die Welt ist aktuell schon ein bisschen am durchdrehen.
Zum Beispiel hat
unsere Bundeskanzlerin
öffentlich von Skypen gesprochen
im Fernsehen 2020.
Also wir haben nicht 2015, 2014,
sondern 2020.
Also eine Software, die seit fünf Jahren
schon echt keinen Menschen mehr interessiert.
Und die hat sich auch nicht
gehalten.
Discorden hört sich auch echt doof an, oder?
Schulen machen jetzt übrigens WhatsApp-Gruppen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es das einzige ist,
was die Boomer-Lehrer bedienen können.
Und WhatsApp kann halt jeder irgendwie bedienen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es nicht
irgendwelche Alternativen dazu.
Und an mir geht das Ganze natürlich auch nicht
spurlos vorbei.
Ich meine, ich habe mir 96 Rollen Klopapier
bestellt online.
Und ihr wisst, das stimmt.
Und ich wurde auf Twitter,
waren sie schon am starten, haben gesagt
Max, das wäre extrem unmoralisch.
Und
jetzt haben sie auf YouTube
auch angefangen, wie unmoralisch das wäre,
dass ich mir 96 Rollen Klopapier bestellt habe.
Ich habe mir da einfach nur dazu
gedacht.
Was juckt's mich?
Dafür kann ich mir den Arsch abwischen, ey.
Und die anderen nicht.
Obwohl ich ein Klo habe mit eingebauter Dusche
und eigentlich so gut wie kein Klopapier mehr brauche.
Ich habe eine Atemschutzmaske daheim.
Und eigentlich habe ich mir
die aber nicht für Corona gekauft.
Die habe ich mir schon vor einer Weile und zwar
für Heimwerkerzwecke gekauft, wenn man mal
Sachen mit Schimmel und solche Sachen wegmachen muss.
Aber ist praktisch, dass man jetzt sowas hat.
Also es passt wirklich,
hat richtig gut zusammen gepasst,
dass ich mir sowas gekauft habe.
Und ja, bevor mir jetzt wieder die ersten Leute erzählen wollen,
Max, das hilft nicht gegen Viren.
Doch, diese Maske hilft gegen Viren.
Glaubt's mir und wenn ihr es mir nicht glaubt,
ich zeige es euch gleich.
Ich zeige euch die Maske gleich.
Das ist nicht so eine popelige, kleine Mini-Papiermaske.
Das ist eine richtige.
Das kann man übrigens Maske nennen, was ich da am Start habe.
Ja, vor zwei Wochen hat uns übrigens
Twitter noch erzählt, dass Corona
natürlich nur alte, reiche Männer
betrifft. Also schon mal
niemand von uns. Ernsthaft, ne?
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Da haben sie sich auf Twitter aufgegeilt,
weil irgendjemand
erzählt hat, weil auf
irgendeinem Live-Auftritt eine Band
gesagt hat,
Corona trifft nur alte,
weiche oder alte Reiche.
Man hat sich so ganz verstanden, Männer.
Oh, und da haben sie sich aufgeregt.
So nach dem Motto hier, das wäre ja schon
so unfassbar,
was hier erzählt wird und so.
Und dann kamen die anderen so nach dem Motto,
ja, wieso ist doch so? Und da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter,
ich muss Twitter
manchmal, ich muss es früher schließen,
bevor ich anfange, mir den Kram durchzulegen.
Durchzulesen.
Also es gab wirklich welche, die darauf
bestanden haben, das wäre so.
Ja, weil Viren da auch
so große Unterschiede machen.
Zumindest ist der Aluhut
allgemein auch nicht weit, denn,
falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet,
wie das Ganze in Wirklichkeit zusammensteht,
aktuelle Verschwörungstheorien
erklären uns das Ganze nämlich. Falls ihr es noch nicht
wusstet, und zwar in Wuhan, in China.
Oder in China,
wie manche Leute sagen.
Ich sage lieber China.
Und Chat, China oder China?
Oder wie man es in Hessen so sagt, China.
Also der 5G-Ausbau
in Wuhan, in China, ist
ziemlich gut. Das ist natürlich ein Zustand,
der ist aus Sicht,
so von, aus deutscher Sicht,
ist da quasi unmöglich.
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Wie kann ein 5G-Ausbau funktionieren?
Das geht nicht.
Das heißt, da kann es schon mal nicht mit rechten Dingen
zugehen, offensichtlicherweise.
Und deswegen muss man
Oder China. China
geht natürlich auch.
der Wahrheit ins Gesicht blicken.
Nämlich, dass Corona in Wirklichkeit
ein 5G-Gedankenvirus ist.
Ist jetzt kein Witz.
Geht wirklich aktuelle Verschwörungstheorien dazu,
die uns das Ganze so erzählen wollen.
Werden zum Beispiel in Zügen Flyer ausgelegt,
5G-Corona-Gedankenvirus.
Ja, weil
5G-Ausbau in Wuhan ist ja auch ziemlich weit
vorne.
Schon bestechende Logik, muss ich sagen.
Naja.
Nachdem
Angela Merkel, also unsere Bundeskanzlerin,
dass sie ja auch selbst in Quarantäne
ist seit, ich glaube, zwei Tagen oder so,
macht sie sich
vielleicht mal ein bisschen Gedanken über das Internet
in Deutschland. Ich stelle mir das gerade so vor,
die sitzt daheim im Homeoffice,
will gerade Putin anrufen
über Skype
und dann muss sie erst mal zur Fritzbox und die Fritzbox
neu starten.
Das kann ich mir so gut vorstellen.
Das kann ich mir so gut vorstellen,
hier einfach bei uns im Internetausbau.
Bis die Merkel ihren Router neu gestartet hat,
haben die Chinesen in der Zwischenzeit
schon zwei komplett neue Internetknotenpunkte
aus der Erde gebuddelt
mit 20 Millionen Baggern.
In der Zeit ist die Fritzbox
noch nicht mal gebootet, bis das hinhaut.
Die Chinesen haben sich
mit dem Bagger bis zum Erdmittelpunkt
durchgebuddelt, Leute.
Bis die Fritzbox von der neu gestartet ist.
Das geht Highspeed
bei den...
Den Vodafone-Support
anschreiben. Ja, Frau Merkel, schicken Sie uns bitte
Ihre Kundennummer. Oh, Ihr WLAN
funktioniert nicht. Das liegt bestimmt am WLAN.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Wie gesagt, Vodafone,
Unity Media, ich hatte in letzter Zeit
schon wieder sehr viel Spaß mit dem Verein.
Tja, was gibt es sonst noch so zu sagen?
Manche haben ja die Hoffnung,
dass das Ganze gut für die Umwelt ist.
Und aktuell, wenn man sich das
Athletenbild da anguckt und
Luftverschmutzungswerte,
ist das aktuell auch ziemlich gut.
Also die Umweltverschmutzung, beziehungsweise
die Luftverschmutzung ist deutlich zurückgegangen.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch klar. Was sagt Ihr eigentlich zu meinem
Atemschutz-Masken-Keks?
Huge-Photoshop-Skills, oder?
Läuft ja auch gerade nichts mehr.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das von langer Dauer
sein wird. Ich glaube, das wird
das komplette Gegenteil werden.
Wenn die Leute, wenn die ganze Corona-Reschichte
erstmal durch ist,
dann werden die Leute erstmal alles nachholen,
was sie jetzt die letzten Monate nicht machen konnten
und richtig abgehen.
Und manche Leute haben vielleicht jetzt auch festgestellt,
oh Mist, so wie das
jetzt ist, wenn wir umweltbewusst
leben, dann ist das ja vielleicht immer so.
Oh ne, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall.
Das geht nicht. Lieber in your face.
Weiter geht's. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Corona
irgendwelche Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt haben wird.
Ich meine, wo kämen wir denn
dahin? Wenn Corona
vorbei ist und alle Leute wieder
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes durchatmen
können, wo kämen wir denn dahin, wenn das
überall auf der Welt auch so sein könnte?
Da muss schon wieder ein bisschen ordentlich
Umwelt- und Luftverschmutzung hochgefahren werden, wenn Corona
durch ist. Da kannst Du Gift drauf nehmen,
dass wenn die Sache vorbei ist,
ist wie als wäre nichts gewesen.
Mich würde alles andere sehr wundern.
Aber eine
Sache frage ich
mich echt. Jetzt ernsthaft mal.
Frag ich mich wirklich. Letztens
kam im Radio so ein Spot
zu Hessen bedankt sich bei Krankenpflegerinnen,
Krankenpfleger, Arzthelferinnen
und Krankenhauspersonal.
Und es ist eine schöne Geste, wenn sich Hessen
bei denen bedankt. Aber ich denke mir so... Fuck, Leute.
Ich hab mich versprochen
im Video. Ich hab nicht
gesagt, Krankenpfleger und Krankenpflegerinnen
und Krankenpflegerinnen.
Ich hoffe, das sehen nicht die falschen
Leute. Kritisch.
Anzeige ist raus. Ja.
Au, au, au, au.
Wenn es doch jetzt, wenn man doch
aktuell so wie viel, 750 Milliarden
oder sonst was aus dem Ärmel schütteln kann für die Wirtschaft,
Bäm, ist da. Warum
kann man nicht den Leuten, die da gerade an vorderster
Front stehen, mal ein bisschen was
von der ganzen Sache zukommen lassen?
Sei es mal so, keine Ahnung, 50% Gefahrenzulage
oder irgendwie sowas. Ich meine, es ist ja gut,
dass viele Leute das aus Überzeugung machen und
das machen auch, weil sie anderen Menschen
helfen wollen. Aber ein bisschen Kohle
können die dafür doch auch bekommen. Warum
gibt man denen nicht mal ein bisschen was ab? Das fände ich
schön, ja. Und bei der Gelegenheit könnte
man gleich noch ein paar deutsche
oder meinetwegen auch internationale
Influencer von YouTube auch
in Quarantäne schicken. Dann
wäre man zumindest von manchen Leuten verschont.
Ähm...
Na gut. Ja, soviel
zum Thema Corona von mir.
Eine gute Sache am Schluss, wo ich jetzt noch loswerde,
hat das Ganze, finde ich, wirklich,
das ist ernsthaft, ähm...
Ich finde, man sieht... Da hat sich
da hat sich einer in den Kommentaren drüber
beschwert, was ich jetzt gleich sage, dass das
Millionen Menschen das Leben kosten wird.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er den Zusammenhang
herstellt, aber guckt dran. Gut,
dass es vollkommen egal ist,
was wir so machen, ähm,
oder es ist gut, dass das jeder Einzelne mal sieht,
dass es, es kommt den Leuten teilweise so
unglaublich wichtig vor, was sie machen, ja.
Und was man daran sieht, ist halt die Welt
dreht sich weiter. Egal für wie
wichtig man sich hält. Die Welt
dreht sich weiter. Und auch eine Sache, wo
ich, wo ich, äh, denke, dass das
die ganze Corona-Geschichte großen Einfluss
drauf haben könnte, ist, dass vielleicht sich
das Thema Homeoffice bei ein bisschen
mehr Unternehmen durchsetzt.
Ja. Aber ich glaube, eine wichtige Erkenntnis
für viele Leute dürfte echt sein, dass man eben einsieht,
hey, egal wie wichtig ich denke,
dass ich bin und wie viel, äh, Sachen
drum herum passieren, die Welt dreht sich weiter.
Mit mir oder ohne
mich. Ist vollkommen egal.
Äh, wir machen an der Stelle Schluss. Ich hoffe,
ja, also ich glaube, dass das wirklich ein großer Vorteil
von dieser ganzen Geschichte ist, weil viele Leute
nehmen das, was sie zu, was sie machen,
viel zu wichtig. Die denken, es geht
ohne sie überhaupt nichts.
Oder wenn sie was nicht machen würden, dann wäre
das, dann, dann ist das der Weltuntergang.
Und was man gerade bei dieser Corona-Geschichte
sieht, es ist nicht der
Weltuntergang.
Es macht, ehrlich gesagt, interessiert sich die Welt
absolut gar nicht
dafür, was irgendein einzelner Typ macht oder nicht
macht.
Bei, bei Milliarden von Leuten sieht es schon wieder
anders aus.
Ähm, so, also es kam die Frage,
wie ich meine G513 Tastatur
finde. Finde ich gut.
Besser, besser als die doppelt
so teure von Corsair.
Ähm, dann
hatten wir noch die Frage, ob ich mal meine
Atemschutzmaske zeigen kann. Ja, kann ich machen.
Zeige ich.
Und zwar
meine Atemschutzmaske
ist
hier. Da ist sie doch.
Da ist sie.
Da ist sie doch.
Und wie gesagt, das ist halt eine richtig
echte.
Also sowas, was man, was man wirklich
Maske nennen kann.
So komplett,
komplett zu. Und die Filter
sind auch gegen Viren geeignet.
Habe ich mir eigentlich gekauft
für mein Metro-Cosplay,
aber jetzt kann ich sie auch für Corona
verwenden. Sogar mit Filter,
ja klar, ohne Filter wäre ziemlich
blöd, oder?
Und das, wobei
mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn irgendwelche
Leute mit dieser Maske rumlaufen würden
und hätten nichts angeschlossen und laufen einfach
so rum. Was gibt's eigentlich?
Ich muss grad mal was holen. Corona
Risitas.
Was, was gibt's da eigentlich so?
Risita, Hamsterkäufe
und Corona.
Corona Klopapier.
Wie lange halten die Filter? Ich weiß es
nicht. Komm, wir gucken,
wir gucken, wir gucken uns doch mal
eine Risitas Verarsche an.
Oder eine Risita
Untertitelgeschichte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die gut ist.
Das ist einfach die erste, die ich genommen hab.
Risitas mit der Schule und digital war gut,
ja.
Na ja, gut.
Na ja,
na ja.
Na ja.
Na ja,
na ja.
Na ja.
Und wichtig, und wichtig ist
Klopapier nicht. Weiß gar nicht,
warum sie sich alle so extrem darüber lustig
machen. Stellt euch mal vor, du hast
keinen richtigen Vorrat Klopapier und du kriegst
wirklich Corona und bist drei bis vier
Wochen daheim. Du musst trotz Corona
scheißen und du kannst nicht einkaufen.
Also ein bisschen Klopapiervorrat
ist nicht verkehrt.
Okay, der Vorrat war echt
ganz lustig.
Okay, der ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Okay, der war
wirklich nicht schlecht.
Babino Bono, Twitch
Prime, Dankeschön.
Gesita
prepares himself for
Coronavirus.
Moment, die machen sich alle über Klopapier lustig.
What the fuck?
Die machen sich alle über Klopapier lustig.
Moment, wir müssen mal
filtern, upload
diesen Monat.
Warum nutzt du eigentlich
Chromium?
Hat keinen tieferen Grund
mehr aktuell. Ich habe mal
ursprünglich Chromium verwendet, weil ich den ganzen
Chromecast gedönst nicht haben wollte.
Ich könnte wetten,
die ganzen Videos sind ziemlich ähnlich vom
Inhalt her.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass es mehr
Risitas gibt.
Das ist viel zu wenig.
Wenn man nach Corona und Risitas
und ich dachte, das ist komplett
YouTube komplett voll.
Shocking interview
about Coronavirus.
Ah, ne.
Supermarkt-Mitarbeiter
packt aus. Okay.
Okay.
Und der Küchenlehrer sagt mir,
Risita, geh in die Paellera.
Komm, geh in die Paellera.
Noch mal digital und Schule Tribut
und schick mir mal einen Link.
Schick mir mal einen Link.
Hast du dir schon mal Opera GX angeschaut?
Ja, haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Ja, sind sie schon hier.
Schau, der Schrank.
Und die Schank.
Alles ausgeschnitten, weil es mir nicht Zeit gab,
die Schank und den Schrank zu schalten.
Ich gehe in die Praxis,
die Maree ist hochgegangen.
Das ist nicht so.
Haben die Könne,
die nichts anderes mehr, außer Klopapier-Witze machen.
Ja, das ist langweilig.
Das ist nicht, das ist nicht,
das ist nicht so gut.
Das ist nicht so gut.
Das andere war lustiger.
Ne, das, der gefällt mir nicht.
Übrigens, das beste Corona-Meme,
was ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe,
ähm,
wartet mal.
Ja, das beste Corona-Meme,
was ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe.
Kann man das Fullscreen machen?
Den Sound, den Sound brauchen wir nicht.
Ich finde das hübsch geil.
Ich finde das hübsch lustig.
Italien fährt hinter China her
und ist gerade dabei,
China zu überholen.
Da kommt die USA von links
mit Corona-Zahlen.
Ja.
Das ist schon ganz geil, ey.
Was, achte auf den Spiegel?
Welcher Spiegel?
Das fand ich gut, ey.
Was, da ist es mit dem...
Okay.
Ach, das hier, ja.
Das ist gut.
Das ist echt gut.
Da hab ich mich kaputt gelacht bei.
Da hab ich mich echt kaputt gelacht bei.
Bei dem hab ich mich,
bei dem hab ich mich,
bei dem, was ich sehe,
da hab ich mich echt kaputt gelacht.
Ich habe mich in den Süden eingelassen, um das Arroz-Restaurant zu öffnen.
Und dann hat mich der Küchenlehrer angerufen.
Ritza, geh in die Paellera.
Die zwei in der Nacht sind schon hier.
Schau, ein Badezimmer.
Die Schankla.
Alles ausgeschnitten, weil es mir nichts geholfen hat, die Schankla zu tragen.
Und der Badezimmer.
Ich gehe auf die Fläche, ich habe die Maree hochgezogen.
Ich habe die Maree hochgezogen.
So, Leute.
Zeitreise in die 90er Jahre.
Ist aber echt so.
Oh, Mann.
POG.
43k Points.
Link zum Bus-Meme.
Ich weiß nicht, was ihr meint.
Ich habe kein Bus-Meme gesehen.
Leute, es ist 22.02 Uhr.
Das heißt...
Ich gucke jetzt mal, ob ich irgendwelche wichtigen Fragen übersehen habe.
Was hältst du von...
Escape from Tarkov?
Würdest du es mal mit...
Der Tio.
Ich würde mit dem Tio prinzipiell was spielen, aber nicht Escape from Tarkov.
Habe ich nie...
Wie gesagt, Battle Royale ist nicht wirklich meins.
Tastatur.
Wie gesagt, die G513.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Leider kann man den hier...
Den...
Ihr erkennt natürlich jetzt alle, was es ist, nur weil ich da drauf war.
Die Handballenablage.
Kann man nicht richtig...
An der Tastatur festmachen.
Das ist ein bisschen doof.
Aber ansonsten ist es gut.
Was ist das denn für ein Board?
Das haben wir im Stream gebastelt.
Das schneidet die Fragen an mich mit,
dass ich nachgucken kann.
Dass ich nichts vergessen habe.
Was für Hoffnungen wird bei Comedy Tragisch sein?
Mesos, habe ich gesagt, habe ich kennengelernt.
Ich kenne mich nicht großartig mit aus.
Half-Life-Brille habe ich nicht gekauft.
Trials of Mana mit Tio.
Ja, aber nicht im Stream.
Das würde ich mit dem Tio vielleicht...
Koop, so spielen.
Kommt eigentlich ein Video zu den neuen Konsolen.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Das hatten wir auch schon.
Und das hatten wir auch schon.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Was wäre dann immer noch besser?
Ein schlechtes Informatikstudium
oder eine gute Informatikausbildung?
Es kommt darauf an, was du machen willst.
Selbst ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium
muss nicht schlecht sein.
Und ein schlechtes Informatikstudium
ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, du hast immer hingepackt.
Das auch nicht jeder hinkriegt.
Kommt darauf an, was du machen willst.
In manchen Bereichen...
Ähm...
Ist es egal, ob du studiert hast.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit auch welche,
die haben studiert.
Und welche, die haben eine Ausbildung gemacht.
Wir haben sogar Quereinsteiger
in ähnlichen Positionen.
Also je nachdem, wo du hingehst,
hat es entweder viel
oder so gut wie keine Auswirkungen.
Im Durchschnitt ist es aber so,
dass Leute, die studiert haben,
mehr verdienen.
Im Durchschnitt.
Das heißt jetzt natürlich nicht,
dass es explizit auf dich jetzt zutreffen wird.
Gut.
Haben wir alles beantwortet.
Sehr schön.
Ich hoffe, euch hat das gefallen.
Eine Runde mal hier spontan.
Streamsoftware.
Zwei Stunden.
Wir sehen uns spätestens am Sonntag.
Wahrscheinlich ein bisschen früher.
Hocken ja alle in Quarantäne rum.
Oder in...
Nein, nein.
Ist ja nicht Quarantäne.
Sozial distanziert sind wir ja alle.
Also können...
Als Gamer ist für uns ja kein Problem.
Wir sind ja immer sozial distanziert.
Homeoffice ist super.
Ja, hat auch vorhin einer gefragt.
Wie ist es im Homeoffice?
Toll.
Ich kann eine Stunde länger pennen.
Oder fast sogar eineinhalb Stunden länger pennen.
Und es geht einem kaum einer auf den Sack.
Super.
Top.
Kann einfach mal in Ruhe Sachen machen.
Das ist sehr angenehm.
Könnt man ruhig weitermachen.
Habe ich echt keine Schmerzen mit.
Einzige, was mich persönlich ein bisschen nervt,
sind die Leute,
die ihre Voice-Chat-Sachen nicht geschissen kriegen.
Ich meine, bei uns heißt das intern teilweise noch...
Jetzt haltet euch mal fest.
Heißt bei uns intern teilweise noch...
Telearbeit.
In manchen Dokumenten
ist es da halt nicht so aktuell.
Leute, die das Mikro an,
müssen sich weigern, Push-to-Talk zu machen.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe eher ein Problem mit Leuten,
die komplett in die Teams-Besprechung reingehen
mit offenem Mikro und dann im Hintergrund
die ganze Zeit irgendwas...
Die tippen ja dann auch so.
Die können nicht normal tippen.
Die müssen dann so tippen.
Ganz grausam.
Und dann hast du die Leute,
die die ganze Zeit noch irgendwelche komischen
Atem-Räusper-Hust-Sonst-was-Geräusche machen, ja.
Du hast wirklich...
Ich frage mich, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Haben die noch nie einen Voice-Chat verwendet?
Da hatten wir heute auch einen in der Besprechung drin.
Der hatte das Mikrofon irgendwie im Mund gefühlt.
Das hat sich permanent so angehört.
Da habe ich gedacht, der ist höchst erregt,
weil er jetzt irgendwie ein Teams-Meeting halten darf oder so.
Also weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Das...
Ich meine...
Hallo!
Die arbeiten alle in der IT.
Die müssen auch...
Die müssen sich auch mit neuen Sachen auseinandersetzen können
und sind nicht total verkacken.
Oh man.
Okay, Leute.
Äh...
What the fuck?
Was war denn das?
Man kann das hier ein...
Wusstet ihr das?
Huge.
Na gut.
Also, Chat.
Bis spätestens Sonntag.
Macht's gut.
See you.